knocked you out
[Music]
is
don't worry are you good
[Music]
it's all good
okay
[Music]
dang that's some good ass music
um that's so good
it's fun we're gonna do the way in the
pre-show y'all
off to my left or right liabella what's
up blue
hey what's up share the show off to my
right your left
brian smith what's up blue 48 shares
that's it 48
on the facebook 48 different groups be
done no more there you go there you go
right now hit the share button
we are the best grassroots conservative
opinion and native voices that you can
have
on your timeline oh yeah
on your timeline we are grassroots we
are
and i know some
um some people put out there who are
these people grassroots
activists opinionators
political commentators that's who we are
and i like to see like months later
somebody will come back and say
whoa you guys were right about that
first but
you creeped me out you were right now i
watch every day if you want people to
follow you
yeah put us on your timeline people will
be like wow
they're in the know i know right mm-hmm
yeah
you get it right ladies and gentlemen we
are being brought to you by
birch gold birch gold
birch versus urgent gold gold is good
take control of your financial future
get yourself some gold what are you
doing
let me let me let me put this up here
real quick
and then i'm going to talk about birch
gold
us inflation is accelerating
and has increased by 2.8
in march from 1.7 in february which is
higher
than expected and we have said this on
the show that it was coming
it's coming ladies and gentlemen the
influential woman
you can't pass all these trillions of
dollars and now they got more coming
you can't tr pass all these trillion
dollars and it not affect american
people
that's why birch gold wants to help
you help you help your family
right yes um to get set up with
precious metals such as gold and silver
exactly precious metals
precious metals they they have
a way to help you out they are the they
are uh
if if not they are among the top
if not the leader in i'm helping you set
up your precious metals as
iras working for your family content
and when they when you talk to them and
they send you this kit that they sent
us they will send you when they talk to
you
they will work with you from the time
you set up your account
and afterwards so they don't leave you
out there alone
they continue to work with you and and
talk to you
they almost become a family member am i
right right i mean they have thousands
of satisfied customers they have an a
plus rating with a better business
bureau
and they have countless five-star
ratings you don't get countless
five-star ratings
from not being a friend you know from
not having good customer service
uh so the comprehensive 20-page info kit
reveals how gold and silver
can help your needs uh your tr you are
there's three steps first off your funds
are transferred to your new custodian
then birch gold helps you purchase the
metals then your metals are stored in a
depository if that's what you wish
uh but in order to get all this done you
first have to call or go to
birchgold.com forward slash wayne uh and
make sure you check it out
also um china's buying up all the gold
they're always ahead of the game i'll be
honest with you i know i we talk about
that a lot but they are
so take it from them if they're buying
gold you should be buying gold
not only that but we got the republicans
currently right now
mulling over the bond administration
new infrastructure trillion dollar
package
i'm just saying those republicans are
going to do it too
yeah you've made so much money in your
401k in the past two to three years
you gotta lock that in you gotta save
that money yep
and if you don't have the 10k laying
around you can use your 401k
or your ira you can use a portion of
that and they'll back it that way
so look into that as well ask them about
it and specialize it
yeah um the video the video that we
showed just a few minutes ago
to start off the show um
that was cnn that was cnn reporters that
wasn't just people
on the side of the road that was cnn's
reporters
uh and for those that join us late let's
let's show it to you again
no no no no no no no no we don't want to
it's all peace
knocks you out of water
it's literally a riot and you've got a
knotted silver scarf
and a leather jacket
i mean this is real life see they're so
disconnected
let me say where did bryan go oh no
he's here with us i don't know where did
i go
damn right from the deep
right you have to turn back on your
camera bud
did did i take my camera off i made me
there you go man
my technological skill holy smoke
i felt like i felt like the cia was
coming for me
like jesus might be jesus
yeah it was like your spirit look i'm
not
do don't get mad with me if i laugh
because somebody threw a bottle of water
at cnn
don't get mad at me y'all i mean
they have been going after us and making
us out to be the enemies
and lying on us and creating false
narratives
and trying to separate us from president
trump the person who we
decided that we wanted to vote for they
and and then
that they've um they've launched these
propaganda things and getting caught
somebody threw about of water at him it
was funny
i mean when in rome what do you think
you're doing you're out of riot
what do you think's gonna happen they're
gonna throw teddy bears and cotton candy
well now we've we see the bully on the
block cnn
uh creating lies and and and just really
enraging uh the people who want truth
and now the people who watch cnn
are now becoming enraged because they
don't quite
understand but but they can hear that
it's not true anymore or that whatever
they're saying that trump's going to
prison russia russia russia and now
we're seeing more
russia interfering with the elections
and that never happened
and it never worked out so you're lying
to both sides
and now the people that you're lying to
are violent
i'm not talking about us i'm talking
about your own
they're violent and they're gonna come
for you
you know uh that that's that that's not
that's not the only
uh video that we have from
last night about cnn they also got ran
off
[Music]
what do you do
what's up
[Music]
[Applause]
tyler what'd they do
it a million times i love the smell of
burnt clutch in the morning
don't you just love it somebody said
somebody said sheila what'd they do
cnn being some [ __ ] he's right right
right you know
you know what's going on and i liked how
he walked into the door
like that was just like perfect timing
it was beautiful i could watch that all
day wait hold on
i'm sorry i'm sorry ladies and gentlemen
we had we have a couple people that just
came into a thing i promise i promise i
i just want to show that one more time
uh cnn has
slammed us they have they've made us out
to be the enemies
don't they lied to their own
people they were praying covenant would
get worse they were hoping you would die
they were hoping you would die and your
children they really were
they do it with prejudice yeah
they said if it bleeds it leads that's
what they say
himself exactly so they're bleeding so
so we see them being run off in
minnesota
[Music]
what do you do
hey
don't want any trouble
tyler what'd they do
[Music]
hey [ __ ] [ __ ] him
i wasn't paying attention i guess but
yeah dude ran
right into it
yeah and you know chris combo can't say
anything because he's the one who said
whose
protests are supposed to be peaceful
right they they gotta eat this
one yeah yeah where does it say protest
after people
well in the first amendment it does say
it does say that
[Laughter]
that was great
ran like a bunch of cowards yeah
yeah i mean i don't i
in watching that i just don't feel sorry
for it i i i know i know
um nance pelosi just well
right before the show oh well actually
no let me look
let's talk about a couple things
yesterday we talked about how aoc
well we showed you a video where aoc was
telling the her activists her little
actress army
that if somebody from their um
families died last year during the covet
situation and it wasn't mark covett on
their death certificate they'd go back
and change it basically
they want to pad those numbers you know
for yeah
um rasheed and philippe went around
saying
that she wants to get rid of uh laura
that she wants to abolish law
enforcement
what what we're trying to understand
is because i have my own uh
uh i mean um idea of what they're trying
to do and by ushering in sharia law
but if you abolish
if you abolish law enforcement
you're hurting regular americans
who ain't got nothing to do with your
political agenda
uh uh ideas or anything you
are hurting regular americans that are
just living their lives
and trying to provide for their families
because
agree with me or not those command
communities that i mean you
you remove law enforcement those
communities were turned into like third
world like type
environments where people are stealing
killing
raping doing whatever
and nobody's coming no nobody's coming
and the reason the reason why they're
doing this and i know a lot of people
are out there and it's upset brian why
would they want this
why would the democrats why would the
republicans why why would
politicians just in general want this
kind of anger this frustration
amongst the people i surmise that that
that as we look at these politicians who
are hateable
they have no authority and their
authority is not just and it's it's it's
not
respectable authority it's awful it's
evil we know they're doing wrong
but as they draw us in and we become
like them
and we become angry and then we say well
they didn't do it
we could do it too then that ushers in
what
what wayne's talking about that ushers
in them saying well this justifies me
bringing in
uh tyranny that iron hand this justifies
the dictatorship because y'all
unruly i know we made you unruly but we
gotta get
we gotta it's done venezuela all over
again
and i can imagine the rest of the
democrat party is not happy with this
squad saying this because they are the
most extreme
members in congress and the least
effective so i try not to pay much
attention to what rasheeda says
because nothing she says actually gets
supported
nor does it get legs i mean it has no
legs obviously you're not going to
defund
the entire police force what would that
do i mean
like you said brian all you're going to
have is a bunch of wild people walking
around
it's going to be utter chaos and
everybody's going to just be getting
shot dead wherever you look and you know
you're going to lose money as a society
as a city if you do that no city wants
that was that
babylon b or was that a real article
that came out yesterday
saying that um saying that they voted to
get rid of the police department
well in minneapolis they did vote for
that right right
yeah they did that they're gonna send to
well no no
they voted well did they vote to get rid
of the police department or did they
vote
they voted to deal with their defending
right
fund and then bring in uh like a social
community right okay
yeah you got a you know a domestic
dispute at the house the guy's punching
the wife the wife throwing the pots and
pans and
things are on fire they're gonna send
you
a social worker to come and talk you
both down off the ledge
you know which what's going to happen is
the husband's going to kill the social
worker kill the wife and then kill
himself
no he's going to get this he's going to
get the social worker and the wife's
going to join him
they're going to get rid of the social
worker and then they'll go back to
fighting again
so so with so with uh so with that
happening
now two new things have come up today uh
the house now we knew that um sheila
jackson lee
and the house democrats
were going to look at reparations uh
this wasn't researching a researcher
it's what it's
it's the middle of april they they
haven't exactly wasted
time they have been researching long so
but now they got notes and stuff that
they're going to send to the
the house to push for reparations
um let me ask you both
do you think reparations is going to fix
things in this country or make things
worse
well i looked into it and i thought what
are they going to do just send 1400
checks to people i wanted to actually
know more about it so i learned a little
bit
and what they want to start off doing
with and i i don't want to say it with
chicago but we'll just for lack of
reason we'll use them as an example
what they want to do is take people that
applied for a loan
between a certain date and year okay so
we'll just say like 1950 to 1970 i don't
know
and they want to take that and they want
to figure out who who was alive during
those times
and who technically could have applied
for loans and then they want to give
them back that money
but they want to do it in a way where
they can only pay for their house
or fix up their house with the money
okay
and they want to take medical marijuana
taxes from that city
and take those taxes and use that for
them
in order to pay for it so that's what
they're talking about
they want you to fix up your house and
make it look better
that's the only thing you can use it for
somebody pissed off leave it
up to the democrats to put literally
like my coach said y'all over there
screw it around like a monkey with a
football
that's what the democrats are like a
monkey running around with a football he
shouldn't have it
it's ridiculous so basically they're
putting limitations on what people
can do with the reparations yeah and you
have to buy lumber at
seven dollars a foot and you can only
fix up your house
so yeah you can't buy a big screen tv
with it it has to be all
just fixer uppers for your house
people on both sides are pissed that the
two by fours used to cost two dollars
and twenty cents
now seven dollars and fifty cents
can't afford that i just don't see that
going down
i know i know hold on how are you
how are they going to
i mean i could see if you if you make it
mandatory for medical only
because they give you a medical card but
to tell me that i'm going to buy
supplies and fix up my house i think
actually brian it's interesting you
brought that up because i think in the
article it said
they were actually going to have some
type of like like some type of card that
you can use
because you had to be a certain age too
you had to be between the ages of like
and 45 at this time frame and like i
said
i don't remember the time frame 16 years
ago which most of these people are
probably
if not dead close to dying right yes yes
exactly so they i mean my dad is 78 and
he was born in 42.
but you see they also said they wanted
government officials like
a certain government entity that will
come and fix up your house you couldn't
just
hire a contractor it had to be
government approved
it was absolutely unclear that needs a
job yeah
yeah yeah it couldn't just be that so
that way you know
say your friend you know is someone that
builds houses
and that could do it for cheaper and
then you can pocket some of the money
and he would just write it that you paid
full price
you can't do that you have to use like
one of their suggested people
you remember comey comey's brother
worked as a cpa for the clinton
foundation
and when obama was elected his brother
went into
construction and got government
contracts to renovate
government business as a cpa
they're here somebody needs a job but
just give them some money
there's your money
you gotta laugh at it because it's
really painful this really sucks
this is an awful lot you know
you know um
if trump runs in 2024 he's gonna have
35 to 40 percent of the black boat
[Laughter]
see i told you they was messing it up
someone asked in the article well what
if i'm a children what if i'm a child
of that person who isn't alive anymore
but still living in the house
this dead the dead answer was no not we
can't help you
that's like biden when that girl asked
dave said uh so you're paying for my
student loans
no we're doing
[Laughter]
uh i mean okay well i mean again and
i mean if just keep going the way it's
going
trump trump might trump may have 165
million
votes in 2024 instead of
instead of um 75
[Music]
another another night of uh
stuff happening in minnesota uh
i don't think it's gonna slow down
anytime soon
i think it's gonna continue and continue
as long as it warms up
i mean hell it was raining the other day
and people were marching and
you know what let me throw this out
there because um
uh a lot of people were talking about
ashley babbitt
ashley bab ashley babbitt this ashley
rabbit that ashley babbitt and i'm like
how many y'all got out there and
protests for asking about it
how many of y'all got out there march
for ashley babbitt
well we have to work so okay but
then take a vacation day but democrats
work
not everybody out there that's
protesting is unemployed
but i've seen a lot of people respond
that they think that everybody out there
is unemployed anybody's not
unemployed that's why the democrats get
what they want and the republicans lose
what they have wayne
they go out and they fight for it yeah
and unfortunately
republicans mirror who vote for them and
i don't see a lot of republicans getting
out there
and and protesting or making a big deal
for ashley
yeah you're exactly right yeah they
don't they don't no no charges
the police officer we wayne played the
video
uh the girl was climbing through a
window uh
the officer had
as a civilian getting a concealed
carried
license it states that i can only use my
weapon
in a threat of death or
extreme bodily injury extreme
dude they won't release his name i said
you will know who shot jfk before you
know who shot ashley back
i promised you that i promise you that
but
i go back to the activism that we were
talking about yesterday
republicans just don't have it and they
don't i mean
they're quick to respond to possibly
getting fired
they're worried about getting fired
i mean fine if that's the case if you're
worried about being fire
we're damn mad then i mean and i and i
ain't saying nothing about covert
we're a man we're i mean we're
we're sun shades we're a wig if you want
to i mean
there's other way where
we're a hat with a confederate thing on
there and and a fake mustache
i mean there are ways to get around it
if you want
to be an activist though but
to to keep hearing all the time well i
work
and and and most most nearly all the
people out there on food stamps it's not
true
it's not true some of those people out
there work hard too
they just when they get home they just
put their stuff on the couch and go out
and find out where they can
um uh where they can uh protest or march
now i don't believe that the people
who well maybe some people who work fast
food
might riot but i don't believe
that people who have jobs everyday jobs
riot
well wayne i also look at they march
i don't i don't believe it people with
everyday jobs right
now right and that's what we're asking
for we're just asking for a protest for
ashley
and here's the thing i think why you're
seeing
the riots and the protests from the left
why they're getting out why they're
doing this why they're taking vacation
days
is because they have nothing else to
lose when donald trump got in they
hit rock bottom at that point they had
nothing that's what they were told
right they hit rock bottom at this point
what what is it what will take
conservatives and republicans to realize
again the democrats get what they want
and we are losing what we had
what will it take for you to go okay i
do need to take a vacation day
i do need to get out there and say
something
the area that should be protesting in
i mean you're talking what dc that's
predominantly
libs i mean it's a giant swamp over
there
i really find it yeah i know you want to
run a protest but i find it hard to
believe
people from virginia from outlying areas
going into dc to protest it just won't
do it
no they won't they won't
um let me see our
talked about the reparations thing what
about the stacking
come on yeah packing and stacking
we keep there's two sides of that
because
i was getting ready to just slam that on
the show today
but i also watched something that said
fdr tried to do it and couldn't do it
and if fdr tried it
he did everything and got away with it
not only to get away with everything
if you don't notice folks google it
google the uh
the second bill of rights he had his own
bill of rights written up
and he was going to put that in and
replace the bill of rights
with his own and just to tip it off uh
medical for all that wasn't built part
of his bill of rights
well and remember joe biden started a
commission a few weeks ago to see if
court packing would be
uh acceptable and a good idea i love
when presidents start commissions
because that means they don't want
anything to do with it
that means they want to fall back right
they want to fall back on the commission
and say well the commission
agrees that it probably wouldn't be good
for america but we'll revisit it later
right
then right down in there
that that was a good sign you say
commission but we know it's just a poll
they're just right under the water well
i'm not exactly what i was going to say
we hear this announcement that democrats
are going to try to put that they want
justices in that's just the trial
balloon they're just testing it out
to see what the public will say about it
i don't think that this is anything
anybody needs to worry about
right now i mean now right now right
like you said um biden is
feeding his people right yeah right but
he's not
serious about it he's not serious about
it he
ain't gonna because you need a
constitutional amendment for that i i
mean i heard
but i'm not sure i'm not talking about
that i just do whatever yeah you just
whip that in i mean
it never i mean there are little they
expanded it before
it's you know it's yeah yeah i mean
there used to be ten and then it went
back to nine
and i mean there is no limit on how many
you can put
we do know that and as as the democrats
got up there today
and just railing and said literally
said uh uh nadler we're not
packing the courts we're unpacking it
we gotta fix what trump wrecked they
wrecked this country now it's our job to
fix what they wrecked isn't it something
isn't somehow they saying that trump
uh uh messed up the court and we know he
it was
fixed slots that were open oh yeah
he's spitting for four years they've
been in for a lifetime
soon the courts will be considered
infrastructure somehow
right when there was i mean exactly yeah
he claimed he claimed national emergency
against russia
yeah i saw that yeah but you know russia
i think we're making uh their people
leave russia
just stay away from that yeah
russia also told him to stay away from
here yeah
yeah i appreciate him ain't playing
no then stuff into law that leads him in
as uh
is a chancellor for life
boris yeltsin never did that never did
that now
boris wasn't drunk he was uh he was a
puppet
putin's former c.i.a or not yeah cia
kgb cia same thing you know whatever
what's the difference
at this point what's the difference
there's no fbi in there too
and he's going to be in there for a long
time because who's going to move him out
he's a killer okay so um yeah no that's
really true yeah that's that's what
biden said
there he is i don't say number oh we
need we
think we're saying i'm saying i'm saying
what biden said is is
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah ladies and
gentlemen let me bring on um our guest
today
she has her own show as a matter of fact
mel coffman show and hello how are you
hi how are you i'm fine um
let let me introduce my co-host uh leah
and brian hi mel hello oh yeah brian
wonderful to meet you all you know i i i
wanted to bring you on i was
i was watching your timeline uh a few
times
and uh
we like to bring on individuals that are
sound in logic and common sense
so when so when you know
you sit in this little hot seat right
here
we want to hear we want to hear a lot of
common sense and logic for our audience
because there's a whole lot of
individuals out there
right now and there's just pushing a
whole lot of uh
crap and there aren't too many people
out there
that can bring the truth
or can uh lead a intelligent
conversation
and um well that's one of the reasons
why we want to have you on
so that people can know a little bit
more about you
give our audience a little background
about you and your show
well my name is mel kaufman i am the i
guess you could say i host an executive
producer of
the mel kafkan show i launched it about
six months ago
um it wasn't supposed to be a political
show i was supposed to be the
conservative oprah
well that's not how things fell into
place
um i've got some great guests that i've
already taped
some more great guests lined up but
after the election i just had to take a
break
uh since you probably felt it really
just put me in a tailspin
and i just kind of you know canvassed
the land i'm like okay
what's going on with the republican
party you know
gop doing mitch mcconnell what were you
thinking
so you know i've got all these spots
going through my head like everyone else
and um i'm so glad i've taken this break
uh we're coming back bigger and stronger
the show
is really a nice solid platform
for conservative ideas and values to be
heard
uh without being interrupted without
being manipulated
so um and plus i'd like to have a little
fun with the show as well
so question um do you have a story of
where
maybe you you made a right turn to be
conservative or have you been
conservative
pretty much raised that way i'm a day
one conservative and no i wasn't raised
that way
was very interesting what used to be
that
the black community in america was
pretty much conservatives
so you know it all started with the
whole civil rights era for some reason
black america has been brainwashed you
must vote democrat
or else you aren't black because joe
biden said
the rhetoric is real just some people
yeah
so um so headley i'm sorry oh no go
ahead
go ahead so i'm here to say that not all
conservatives look alike
a voice is a voice and all voices
deserve to be heard
freely uninterrupted without propaganda
without mind control all these other
things and
i was just a lady sitting at home saw my
country going up to smoke
and i've been working on the show idea
for years and that's what made me just
put it into full effect so you said you
took a break after the 2020 election
to kind of observe and reflect and i
think that's a great idea i think
everybody should take a break
from social media and really reflect and
observe so during that time period what
i want to just pick your brain
what do you think the biggest issue is
right now facing gop
for me personally what i observe is
there's a lack of trust i read a poll on
my twitter page
my personal and uh mail underscore
kaufman
and over 20 something thousand people
responded
i think it was like 98 of those people
prefer to be called trump supporters
versus republicans
but rather most conservatives will
prefer to say i'm a conservative or a
trump supporter
i've also uh tweeted about what it means
to be a conserva
trump supporter it's not about trump the
man of course we like him we love him as
president
but it's more about those values those
virtues
putting god country and family first
amen and again i i know a lot of people
i'm from cincinnati
a lot of people are here on the west
side you still still now to this day
i'll go to people's houses and they
still have trump flags flying
and talking about trump and talking
about this and that and i think what it
was was that trump
resonated with with the core america
american
core values of the founding of this
country
your thoughts i would agree with you um
what happened to me i was eight years
old and um
it was election it was an election year
and they had a
in the school auditorium had a
conservative representative and a
and i i guess democrat conservative and
what i heard was
well black people keep complaining about
the same old thing
you know this this and that so why do
they keep promoting democrat
and that was pretty much the defining
line for me just kind of a little
history there
so um i lost my train of thought but um
would you ask me again i'm sorry just
just the fact that people i think people
attach themselves to trump when in
reality
uh they're they're attaching or
reattaching themselves to the roots and
the founding of america
and i think that's where i was getting
to with that comment yeah i mean america
is
based on the premise of inalienable
rights personal freedoms which are
divine rights
and no one has a right to take that away
from anybody
or to squash out a voice or a thought
even if you don't disagree with it
and and in saying that with freedoms
come consequences
you can say what you like however be
prepared for the consequences good or
bad
you know so those you know i say that
i say that about freedom of speech uh
because so many people throw it up
throw that throw that term up freedom of
speech freedom to speak through
i was like okay well you can say what
you want to say
it's just consequences that come with
behind that
i mean and i think on our side
yeah when i speak about outside i see it
loosely because
um sometimes i don't know well i know
i'm not on the left but
sometimes i have to wonder about sides
and stuff but
mo most most people on our side
know that consequences come with freedom
of speech
but when you talk about the when you
talk about people on the left
they just feel not only can they say
what they
want and not get in trouble but they can
attack and destroy and call that
freedom of speech and that is not even
close to being freedom of speech am i
right
i would agree with you another good
strategy that i see that's been working
for the left
is as conservative we really need to
embrace this younger generation we need
to get
younger people groomed for the political
and leadership positions
and just basically um stop allowing the
other side to deserve to
to uh define what conservatism means
stop giving them you know the
i guess the rights per se to define who
we are
our voice should stand no matter what
and we should not let anybody
overshadow us over speak us etc what
worries me
is not only do you have the democrats
though and yes our votes count but
these monopoly companies that are siding
with the democrats
and making a huge influence on what's
going on in this country
including you know pulling out the mlb
game uh in georgia
taking millions of dollars from black
run
businesses and putting it right in the
hands of white random businesses in
colorado
just because in the name of racism which
doesn't even make sense why they did
that
but there's power in numbers and these
it's almost as if like
both parties don't even matter at this
point it's what these big businesses are
doing
that's where my worry is now you made a
very good point
do our door votes really matter this is
tony
you know president trump he exposed a
lot of things that a lot of people were
you know we always kind of knew there
was something going on behind the scenes
you know
do we our votes really as free and
authentic as we think they are
well if things are going to exist as
they are
you can audit and all day long but if
the same voting machines are
still going to be in place the same
companies the same allegiances
what's the point of talking about 2022
and 2024
when 2020 hasn't been addressed has been
in terms of the electoral process
right now there are some big issues and
big problems on the table here
and you know i really think it's going
to take people like us to just
get the message out there that reminds
me of what rand paul did
a couple years ago with the big tent
thing
ramp uh uh after they had lost
after the gop had lost the election i
think um
with mccain i think that's when the big
ten
thing big study came out we need to
expand increase our big ten and bring
people in
well there was a big gigantic book that
they came up with but after that study
was over
nothing i mean it took trump in uh
in uh 2016 to
listen and hear our voices and then
go on the rallies and talk to
i said in this show i in all my life
i've never heard a
presidential uh candidate get in front
of a crowd
and say i love you that's right right
i i had never seen that i had never even
seen
a presidential candidate in my lifetime
get out on the streets of detroit and
walk the neighborhood
and shaking hands
so i mean the template or the blueprint
is
out there for the gop and
it's like they're just throwing in a way
and thinking that well you know we'll do
it
the way we want to do it we'll use his
name though
but we'll do it however we want to do it
well that's not working very well for
them like my inbox
flooded with you know uh
money donation requests and rnc and i'm
and i'm just like
no no no no you didn't do what you were
supposed to do
and you know right now uh president
trump is pretty much running the
republican party
i was reading something the other day a
quote by mitch mcconnell
where he he stated you know he was
enlisting trump's help to
make him senior majority leader again
exactly
right well you brought a brand
and and i know there's a lot of rand
paul people out there i understand and
whatnot but i'm gonna tell you right now
is dark and as dirty as
some of these politicians are back in
the day we had a tea party
rock star by the name of matt bevin in
kentucky that was going to unseat
uh old crazy crazy yeah
cocaine mitch yeah and uh rand paul at
the last minute said
nah i think we're gonna keep cocaine
mitch not matt
matt became governor yeah but still
we got pro we got a misconception of a
concept here
you know and and and i remember back in
the days too because i i had somebody
from tea party because i kept railing on
mitch
we got to get rid of it uh both somebody
else
and during one of those outings i had
somebody walk up to me and say
um you know some of the top people
want you to stop downplaying mitch
i'm like what first of all i was like
wait they listen to the show
really yeah
i think you learned something yeah i
know yeah really
why do you want us because yes bevan can
beat mitch
but bevin can't beat the democratic
um uh opponent mitch can beat the
democratic opponent
i was like well maybe if y'all got
behind the other guy but
the other guy would be able to beat
this is your opponent i'm like
y'all backwards man y'all y'all keep
putting this guy in here and
the guy keeps hurting us well
you know that goes back to who's really
who who
knows who are true conservatives
[Music]
well i tell you what now where can uh
everybody just loving what you have to
say
where can they find you where can they
watch you what's your twitter
i'm all over the place wherever you guys
are i am i'm not
god if i want i heart i want everything
here's the thing um
i have not promoted the show and i did
it on purpose
i had an outstanding media meeting with
vaynermedia about three weeks ago and
they love my strategy
we came up with some ideas so the show
is getting revamped and it's going to be
taken to a different level
but uh you can check out my website uh
mel kaufman show.com
so uh youtube instagram
uh my tagline is that tell it to mill
and i will put that
chat here um so i'm pretty pretty easy
to find
thank you mel thank you so much i i know
i know it's probably a surprise
but i mean like
i said people like when people said uh
not to do something i'm like wait a
minute they watch me
uh i watch youtube
oh no i want you to i watch you and i
mean i appreciate
i appreciate um what you're doing uh
because i remember when i first started
it wasn't a lot of us
uh no i've been following you for a long
time
what a black conservative
but no i appreciate you uh and your
spirit because we need we need more
people
we need more people out there uh uh
breaking down barriers and explaining
who we are and why we think the way we
do
in a way that is not confrontational but
is objective and also informative
and i believe that's what you're doing
and i'm 100
well we're 100 behind you and if you
need us to do anything let us know
stay in contact will and let me know
when it launches so that we can promote
it and have you back on so that
you know and you know so
yeah bernie harrigan and uh
congressman van taylor district texas
district three
and he gave a phenomenal interview very
um very entertaining insightful believer
and it was entertaining
um very passionate both were stellar
guests
so um i've got some very exciting guests
coming out so
okay all right we're working on it well
look i look forward to seeing it and
sharing it
and um i'm praying for you thanks so
much
thanks guys bye-bye have a great day
ladies and gentlemen as you know a whole
lot of us guys
yeah um yeah leo you're not a guy but um
thank you you're welcome a whole lot of
us guys are being attacked
yeah that's right those guys are being
attacked
i saw i found a video last night um a
young woman
asked a question what is it like being a
man in today's society
so is there a video with that i'm sorry
yeah yeah
okay we're coming i just want to see
what everybody's going to say when they
watch it
the andrew 2 6 1 0 one show
what is it truly like to be a man in
today's society what are the
difficulties
let's see there's no point in getting
married anymore because divorce is
basically incentivized why would an
aging woman who's losing her sexual
market value want to be with a man
when she could just take his money and
his children and his house
you can't be sexual at all to women
anymore or else you might get canceled
everyone believes women when they make
false rape allegations and even if
they're proven to be not true
your reputation is still damaged for
life a woman with buyer's remorse can
basically just
make false claims or exaggerated claims
about you and you're damaged for life
women want you to do and provide
everything for them and change into
whatever they want you to mold into
but don't want to change at all
themselves and society praises this
women always talk about how they want a
man above six feet but when a man talks
about how he wants a fit chick he's body
shaming
nobody has our backs not even our
brothers men destroy men in the name of
women because they bite night we're
completely
disposable in today's society and nobody
cares
he's just realizing that now i'd like to
know what kind of relationship he has
with his mom
ew i don't i don't want anything about
that no not that way
no i'm just saying his relationship with
women are not very good and that stem
that begins with your mother
if you don't have a good relationship
with your mom you don't have a good
relationship with women
and i also think it has a lot to do
where you live do you i mean
i feel like maybe he's in a liberal city
i don't think he's out in the middle of
the country somewhere because honestly i
am and that is not how the women treat
the men and that's not how the men treat
the women
it is really a wonderful experience out
here where i live at least
he could be he could be speaking on a
national thing too because
a lot of men are sh i'm ashamed
now he made some very good points yeah
um and the way the way the way that we
are being
uh treated by the women's side i mean
almost to the point where you're trying
to cancel
all men superheroes on comics that i
mean
that's crazy in itself uh the
uh abc or no cb abc
nbc um
nbc's morning program or if you look at
a lot of the news programs
they've gotten rid of a lot of the male
posts they have pushed women hosts
because a lot of the men who have been
granted sexist chauvinists
for over the years and getting away with
it
in the last couple years they've been
called out and got in trouble and kicked
off so they could
push more women now what are they going
to do though when the women start doing
that
when all of a sudden the women start
getting that complex right
and i think we're living in a society
now where the society is now
flipping the rolls uh and this kind of
goes back to something i was thinking
about this morning
especially with with the shooting uh the
other day and the female cop or whatnot
and and i really i think i was light
with it yesterday but but
i'm gonna push it this is to the end uh
female
women do not have the or shouldn't
be given arbitrarily authority
that that they don't deserve to have
authority over
other men to have this authority in a
position like that
for the marines and the army to lessen
the the requirements
for combat individuals to be female to
get in
you're given this authority that
shouldn't be given to them and we're
having problems with that
and now we're starting to put women into
a light of that
they need to run everything now and
that's not true
well and the reason everything and why
is that anybody asking a question why
are they trying to do that i can tell
you why
there's too much population if they can
get women to run things then they
have women are too busy to raise
families women are too busy to have
children they don't want you having
children anymore that's why they're
pro-transgender
that's why they're pro-abortion that's
why they're pro-women
run everything now go ahead and be a cop
go ahead and host a morning show
just stay busy so that way you don't
want to feel like you're being held down
by your husband
so that way you don't feel like you're
being controlled by a man that way you
don't have to have children
they it's population control you see
what they did i mean
mitt romney's a goofball there's i'm not
but did you see what they did to his
wife
she raised five pretty decent boys for
as much as i know
they're successful they're well off
they're doing a pretty good job in their
own
individual lives they're not drug
addicts and it's
like basic guns around right
right but but did you see what they did
to mitt romney's wife when she went on
the view
and when she went on some of these they
ripped her down they
really killed her and made fun of her
for being a what is
oh you stayed at home well look at it
remember what they did with acv but five
kid
i only got three there's no way and and
they're not boys
two girls and a boy how do you raise
five boys
i don't know remember how amy comey
barrett was asked well how are you gonna
do this with five kids
really well just not this just know this
it might look like a daunting test for
raising five boys but when they grow up
boy you got an army yeah
[Applause]
let's get going they don't want you
having five kids anymore they don't even
want you having one kid
they want they want a man to be feminine
so that way he doesn't want to have sex
with a woman and they want the woman to
work so she feels manly and she don't
need a man
and then you don't have kids but i've
been thinking about this
if we have a larger population have more
of a workforce though
they don't want a larger population they
want a smaller population
because because the world can't hold
that many people
i don't know talks about in ted talk he
explains it actually very quite well
yeah he wants to um he wants to
control the population in africa right
now
oh wow but we got so much land here i
mean just driving i know i know we do
don't we
from cincinnati to maryland cincinnati
to maryland yeah
like 90 percent of that's nothing but
right grass and trees
who's buying it up bill gates is buying
it up right
here but i'm just saying that there's
just so
much to live on yes yeah well
he doesn't want you to all roads lead
back to george soros bill gates and
ccp well i mean the federal government
is buying up land too and calling it um
uh historic national
treasure yeah property or something so
you can't
you can't till on it you can't fertilize
it you can't do nothing to it
and uh whatever um d d from carbona says
hello
i just want to put that out there uh
what's up d
i got before i before we go i gotta
email it
look i get emails like this all the time
i just
i just wanted to uh it's not another bad
one is it
yeah i just i just want to
um read this because i kind of figured
i have people on facebook twitter all
i type stuff and they follow me i don't
check my timeline like that
all the time i'm not always on my
timeline
to read all of the problems that people
get into
when they open up their mouth if you say
something
if you give an opinion thank god thank
you
but if somebody responds to you in a way
that you don't like block them
if it comes to a threat report him
oh yeah yeah yeah
i can see that this young lady last
night your show posted something about a
felon
who was fatally shot accidentally i made
a post
since my post my son and myself have had
our lives threatened
literally and the one thread of the
creeps commenting
actually posted a picture of me and my
son saying that he would kill my boy
i am shocked and disgusted that you
would allow such threats on your post
what i am personally i i personally was
then threatened by a black female dude
i am unfollowing your show thanks
that has nothing to do with you it has
nothing to do with me
you're not policing those the company
that runs it
supposed to be policing and they do a
pretty good job considering every single
conservative is shut down
on that site that you're talking about
he's running it he's running to some bad
people
she's she's run into some bad people on
the internet
that could be totally fake they could be
fake accounts that are coming after you
if you can't take the heat if you can't
take the heat get out of the kitchen
social media is a very dangerous place
people commit suicide over how bad
they've been bullied on social media so
if you think you're going to be able to
get on social media and say what you
want and not be judged for it
sorry you're in the wrong place stay at
home shelter in place put on your mask
and don't tweet because you aren't gonna
be able to handle it
where do you think they got the picture
of you and your son
maybe from your account they walking
down your street
yeah i mean if you put yours
your pictures on facebook
and you gave the approval for people to
look at it
that's on you i don't have anything to
do with that i
i don't know you i don't know you from
tom dickinson i i i don't know
and again i don't spend time
going all up and down my timeline
looking for people that are going after
other people
i you would waste literally your whole
day because that's all it is
that's all it is yeah that's all it is i
mean
i remember i had a story out there one
time
and they had millions and millions and
millions of views
and i knew it was viral but i didn't
look at
the responses i just whatever you know
it's it's going viral
somehow somewhere it found its way to my
ex-wife's timeline and she don't even
follow me
it was just somebody from her timeline
somewhere
in her universe saw what i had put
and since we have the same last name or
had the same last name you know they
kind of
put it and she was like well she went
and started looking at some of the
comments and she
she started worrying she was like do you
see what these people are saying about
you i said no no
no can't let it bother you no i might
like
look at the if i have something that
goes viral like there's a couple things
like tic tocs gone like quarter mil half
mil
i look at that like the fi first couple
of comments
i like i put up a joke one that was just
a joke i was
shocked at how many people believed
oh it was jeffrey epstein from the dead
saying something now and bill gates tell
him to shut up people believed it was
i'm like no it's a joke people
i had to stop i was getting angry it's a
joke
it's a joke
it's crazy it's crazy i mean look
we tell you to about to voice your
opinion we also
want you to have nerves of steel we also
don't be afraid to voice your opinion uh
mel
is not afraid to put herself out there
and create her own show
and have her voice heard you can't
change this world unless you open up
your mouth
if you keep your mouth shut everything's
gonna stay the same
that's if you don't want the drama then
then don't then then keep your mouth
shut
it's going to follow opinions polo with
drama always
everybody's not going to respond
beautifully to what you have to say
it's not that type of world it's not
it's not that type of route
whatever man huh you know you know you
piss me off man sometimes
i responded bye yeah
you should have told her to take a gummy
from cbd line
um that would have calmed her down cut
back on the anxiety
oh yeah you can take one i'll open them
up for you boy they smell good
you know they have orange i just
discovered orange a few days ago i
didn't really
i already knew it well
you know then you got your my pillow and
when you're laying there after taking a
gummy from cbd line you're laying there
on your
your mattress topper your beautiful
pillow because you get the combo
together
you can daydream about your money and
how that's being secured
by birch gold yeah just a beautiful
evening
like i said this is the holy trinity of
self-care and i believe self-care
self-care is health care get your money
right get your mind right and get your
body right
and then you will be right with the
world and don't forget i want everybody
in the chat to write down their
questions for
4 20 because cbd line will be coming on
uh there's going to be some surprises
but we want you to write down your
questions so that way you have them
ready
for when they're on they'll answer them
directly you're going to receive 20
off all you have to do is go to
cbline.com go ahead and start shopping
on there and at the end you'll just use
the code word wayne and you'll actually
get 20
off your total order the whole store is
20 off they've got chocolates they've
got gummy
wayne is eating probably more gummies
than he should but that's all right
stressful day um also they are
well they have chocolates they've got
gummies they've lotions they have oils
something for
everybody so make sure you get there
kathy says wayne cbd line wouldn't let
me get the pen so we will talk to them
about the pen
on 420 because i know that's a big
question for people
yeah yeah it's something that came down
from congress but we gotta fix
well i think it was congress right yep
yeah
well it's when the big big tobacco
companies uh
get their monies threatened and they
have to do something to uh
yeah circumvent the rules make new rules
that's all they did
all right i'm cool i'm cool because if i
laugh too much then y'all gonna think
that this thing made me crazy in this
dancing
but no i'll testify he already crazy
guys
nothing to do with the gummies that's
good though
all right um well you know this is our
friday
yeah we'll um we do do a show on
censor oh yeah we
yeah you know what i've had people
contact me they're like dude
you still doing that show like yeah
somebody over at censored needs to
every friday friday we do a show for
censored whether censor puts it up or
not ain't got nothing to do with us
it is true we do do a show and we know a
lot of people have joined censored
especially to watch the show so we're
going to make that happen for tomorrow
night
yeah yeah but by hooker crook we will
make it happen tomorrow night okay
um with that said
uh ladies and gentlemen we thank you
follow us on our social media
um we thank you for tuning in to the
show and um
whatever you do stay out of trouble this
weekend
yeah i don't know for real and stay out
of minnesota don't don't
stay out of the big cities yeah i mean
you know just hang in the country just
hang hang in the country take a big old
towel or picnic towel
okay and go to the park
and hang in the park sounds good and if
you don't have a park
go to a countryside and you know
hang there we do that we go fishing down
the crack
we call [ __ ] here we don't call them
creeks we come crazy
yeah we go fishing down the creek i
ain't saying number one no damn fishing
killing animals look at you why are you
killing us oh i love how you spin that
cnn
smith i got a quick
i got a quarter
all you liberal vegans well there might
be some conservative beacons out there
but um i don't think that's a myth
no such thing you know you know how
vegans get mad because we eat meat
yeah they get twisted panties on bunch
well y'all drink water don't you
yeah don't water uh
house the fish oh yeah so ain't you
killing the fish
or draining they're draining their legs
out
i i'm just yeah
quit drinking water are vegans okay with
abortions
that's a good question because uh the
liberals are expanding those
opportunities
so yeah so can you be a vegan
is in the chat room hi d.a okay um
what's up d.a can you be a liberal and
the district what's up what's going on
quit distracting people what's up dude
it's a live show bro i know what the
hell is wrong with you man
what are you thinking what are you doing
here damn you
you're cracking you you didn't you
didn't made her go crazy
here i am trying to prove a point about
vegans and abortions really gonna get on
here
we talking about immigrants wrote um
illegal immigrants
hitting borders
[Laughter]
thousands of kids are coming across the
board it's like hey
man you just took the show and run it to
a bridge above me
he did he did
one thing i've been waiting all day for
this i'm losing weight i'm losing weight
you look good i thought that too you
look good
your color is a lot better too yeah okay
the color's a lot better you used to
have dark rings right here she said it
he had dark rings right here and now
they're not they're not there anymore
would you just take a damn compliment
she said you're
you're starting to lighten up i didn't
listen here's cnn smith that i'm gonna
stick with you that name's gonna stick
with you buddy boy
i'm telling you you're almost there
to where these fans of yours start
calling you seasons
[Laughter]
that was kind of cool so what were you
saying
[Laughter]
there you're looking good yeah so
um i weigh myself every
every friday did you know that um
i i feel like i mean i've gone down a
shirt size
but it doesn't make sense and pro and
and then we'll leave but does it make
sense that you can lose weight but it
doesn't
show that you're losing weight yeah it
turns
fat weighs more yeah well fat and muscle
weight differently
fat is bigger but this size
of fat might be this big but the size of
your muscle is
smaller but they weigh the same so you
may be losing
fat weight but turning it into muscle
which makes you feel and look thinner
but the scale might not change so it's a
stay away from you you'll lose weight
yeah you'll lose weight but water weight
will come on but the next day it'll go
and then it'll come on so like you may
have lost five pounds but you had a
little bit extra salt
so friday it'll look like you only lost
two but then the next friday will look
like you lost seven
it's because that water weight
fluctuates so give yourself a good month
until you can actually
figure out exactly how much you're
losing but still weigh yourself every
friday
then you'll start to learn yeah stay
away from sodium and sugar
and drink men men our age need to be
drinking
a hundred and twenty eight ounces a day
of water
and that's the case that's to clean you
that's how old are you
i'm younger you are i know that that see
men your age
i was talking for the grandparents
i have to say this i have to say this
because uh i've been eating
a whole lot better for the last two
weeks seriously
i've been eating better i
tried chipotle
two days ago yeah yeah it was only it's
really the only thing that i've really
had that day
i think i i think i am lactose chipotle
right now
hey you know chipotle almost lost there
for a minute
yeah what was it e coli yeah but no good
is what it was
i don't eat that well yeah i could i
mean because
i've been in that situation before where
you know you stopped drinking soda you
stopped eating ice cream
when i was in the military i was losing
weight too for
for a certain thing i stopped doing that
and then when i started eating ice cream
ice cream again you know so uh
really eat ice cream well i got back to
eating ice cream but i couldn't eat ice
cream like i wanted to because
it was almost like i was lactose
intolerant now
that that's why i haven't read chipotle
yeah i was like i'm done
no more yeah no i'm done
but i but i hope that um you know we're
we we're doing a lifestyle change for
the whole family
and i've been doing a whole lot of the
special cooking and
and everything like that and um
you know some people are like no you
gotta eat meat you know we're
you know we conservatives well it's not
true
if you're not healthy though you got to
make some changes and
for yourself uh nine guys on a
professional nfl team nine guys on the
team
went straight vegan the whole year the
greatest year they ever had
oh really yeah i got to see blood flow
whenever you eat meat versus not and the
blood flow slows down
so much like it freaked me out how slow
it is it almost looked like you were
ready to have a stroke
i mean the blood flow whenever eating
vegetables was this fast literally
and then when you eat meat for 12 hours
after that it goes like this
chocolate chili and sugar well i feel
like i'm gonna take a nap and i'm like
oh i'm gonna
maybe watch the meat yeah yeah i haven't
i haven't had
beef or meat in the last couple of weeks
so
i mean but i've been killing the chicken
though i mean i was gonna say kfc don't
count it's not really chicken
i love miso kfc
[Laughter]
there's a whole lot of people getting
mad because of that too i mean
you know you know that rumor was out
there for a while and kfc was
they started losing a whole lot of
things they're like they lose me
i hate squirrels they lose me
do you think that their original recipe
used to be better than what it was
before yeah i think when i was kid i
think it was much better i feel like
i feel like it's missing something i'll
tell you a fun fact
yes it's too soggy my uncle uh he used
to collect antique books
and there was the original recipe in one
of the antique books and he sold it
and um they had it was pancake mix the
flour was made out of pancake mix
that's all i can remember i was a little
kid now they i'm sure talk different
seasonings and stuff
but yeah pancake mix was their main
secret
ingredient i realized that
when you get original from
kfc now by the time you get home your
box is
soggy so yeah right but they've also
changed up the oil
yeah they've changed up the oils now fda
regulations all kinds of stuff we're not
a lot of
good things that taste good nothing's
fun anymore
coconut oil make your popcorn at home
that's how they did it in the theaters
back in the day that's why they were so
awesome
coconut oil yeah and you know it's funny
you say that because i was watching
something and um they uh some people got
sick from the movie popcorn
because the movie popcorn uh
for some place they use real butter
they'll put on their real butter
yeah but the butter gets old oh
and it gets hard the stapleness of it no
you get this
something and i mean it's nothing
even though it's melted and put on your
butter it's still bad butter and
it makes you sick on the inside so yeah
you've been watching the the pre-show my
name is wayne dupree
leah bella blue eyes and blue eyes cnn
smith that's kind of funny
uh we want to appreciate well we
appreciate you watching the show and we
appreciate
you sharing the show and for those that
continue
to come back thank you so much for those
that decided
that um this is your last show
i ain't even gonna be smart y'all have a
good weekend too
[Music]
okay